the accused knew that there was a person
behind the toilet door he chose to use a
fire um which was a little weapon he was
competent in the use of firearms as he
had undergone some training I now revert
to the relevant questions first would a
reasonable person in the same
circumstances as they accused have
foreseen the reasonable possibility that
if he fired four shots at the dog the
toilet whoever was behind the door might
be struck by a bullet and died as a
result the second question is would a
reasonable person have taken steps to
guide against that possibility the
answer to both questions is yes the last
question is did they accused fail to
take the steps which he should
reasonable have taken to God against the
consequence again the answer is years he
failed to take any step to avoid the
resultant death I am of the view that
they accused acted too hastily and use
excessive force in the second census it
is clear that his conduct was negligent
I will have to stop here we'll proceed
tomorrow morning at half-past nine